we've had some really good audience
questions I feel like we've had a solid
month or five weeks in a row pad where
it's just been fantastically good
audience questions and that is no
different today our first question is
from Danny what is absurdly overpriced
in your opinion I have a lot of thoughts
on this I mean water it depends that we
want to approach this most things in
America's biggest cities are very very
overpriced and this includes everything
from apartment rent to real estate to a
lot of services that depend on human
labour the rent is too damn high the
rent is too damn high as Jimmy Williams
told us back in when was that was that
2012 I think on to the right the 2012
presidential primaries anything that you
would buy at the movies right like a
soda or popcorn at the movies that's
outrageously overpriced internet in the
United States Internet that is not even
that fast I find to be overpriced in the
United States it really depends on what
you're talking about there are cocktail
bars now in Boston where a cocktail
costs eighteen US dollars that's
outrageous to me that just seems crazy
particularly when if it costs 18
you'd better not tip $1 you'd better tip
at least $2 you're talking about a $20
cocktail really we're talking about a
couple bucks and ingredients couldn't
you get away with charging $11 for that
cocktail which in many parts of the
country by the way would still be very
high but no longer in Boston like you
expect to pay 11 or 13 dollars for a
cocktail at any reasonable cocktail bar
there's such such a long list of things
that are absurdly overpriced I guess but
I mean if people are going to these
upper end restaurants and bars they can
afford to pay it it's okay with me
that's a market a defense it's a market
apologia well it's interesting that you
bring up popcorn and movie theaters and
you can even extend that to like a beer
at a ballgame for example to go yeah
obviously those going to be highly price
highway robbery
but you know that going into it because
they have you by the balls at that point
you already paid to get in there you pay
for the cost of admission you're not
just going to leave and get that
somewhere else yeah and you're going to
just either pay or not get it at all
what's the most expensive sports item
price you've heard of
like from anywhere l entry $12 beers at
ball game Wow
that's how we're like a little cup like
I don't know right we're not talking
about like a 10% alcohol imported unique
beer that you might you know like it's
like a larger one particularly you might
get it a beer bar you're talking about
like a 10 ounce cup of Bud Light or
something like that oh well maybe I mean
if you're going to pay nine dollars for
a Bud Light or Coors Light or a Miller
Lite why not just spend an extra two
dollars and get something that's
actually tasty what about a lot of like
health and beauty products like various
creams I actually met not that long ago
with the CEO of the immense cream and
shaving products and shampoo company and
he basically told me there is very
little cost difference in any of the
creams you see like a lot of the creams
are marketed specifically towards women
but not all and you see tiny little
containers of an anti-wrinkle cream sell
for 20 30 40 or even 50 dollars and
really the differences the CEO told me
between these products comes down to
texture of the product scent of the
product and then marketing the physical
of the physical container that these
creams come in and the marketing around
it but that really there's only a
handful of actual ingredients that are
used in so-called moisturizers or
so-called wrinkle preventers or decrease
or whatever the case may be that seems
like quite a racket to me well it's
going after markets where these people
are very sensitive so let's say you have
wrinkled skin for example which is
obviously natural and not something you
should be ashamed about - you know you
may try to get a quick fix at first by
the $10 cream and it doesn't work and
then you find a $50 one and think well
this is five times as expensive if
anything's going to work it's going to
be this that's one of the ways that in
economics we consider even though supply
and demand are sort of independently
determined in total rational
neoclassical economics you can actually
impact demand based on the supply you
can increase prices artificially or
decrease supply artificially to create
the perception of a luxury good
so if Mercedes came out with a seven
$18,000 car and you know what they might
have one in Europe there's really small
Mercedes and Audi and whatever in Europe
but let's say Mercedes came out with a
$17,000 American car it might do well
but it might not because part of what
makes the brand of mercedes-benz
attractive is that it is expensive and
that people associate the fact that it's
expensive with better quality and this
is something that could be happening
with the creams which is know let's
create the perception that it is better
by making it more expensive and I think
that's sort of what you're alluding to
yes definitely another example I would
give is college textbooks I think too
because let's say you're you know you're
paying for your kid to go into school
freshman year out rate already signing a
check for $50,000 to have the tuition
and to have them live there or anything
else so if you're paying you know $200
plus per textbook it doesn't seem like
it's that much more but of course you're
getting ripped off I mean I uh I
announced earlier this week that I will
be a professor I am going to be
Professor Pakman at Boston College
starting in the fall is that how I
should address you by all means address
me that way and people in the audience
do and I will not be requiring any
textbook purchases I'm creating an
electronic reader where I am going to
get a combination of scanned individual
chapters and online articles and
whatever I am NOT going to I'm not going
to participate pat in the college
textbook industrial complex it's always
pretty sketchy to me when the professors
would have their own books on my
absolutely required reading I've had
many classes like that yeah